Andrew Tate has this quality that I  think Alex Jones has Alex Jones has this  quality where he very often says true  things in the least believable way  possible so he'll say something that's  true he'll say like like two plus two  equals four but instead of just saying  two plus two equals four he'll be  ripping his shirt off and you know  screams like two plus two equals four  actually is very often true and and  Andrew Tate has this issue here he's  saying hey women you should be more  modest and not allow yourself to be used  by a bunch of dudes that will actually  in the long run make you more attractive  to men and more attractive to better men  but he somehow manages to say it in the  most vulgar and grotesque and defensive  way he possibly can but the point is  totally true